let's conduct an experiments just go and
Google these two words Donald's and
Trump what did you get when you googled
them well I'm sure you found lots of
results about his latest tweets his
latest bold statement or maybe his
latest sexual scandal but you probably
had to click to the second or even the
third page to find out anything about
what is actually one of his biggest
political bets we're talking about
something that might change the
International economy it might change
the price of oil and the fate of two
countries yes dear viewer I'm talking of
course or maybe not of course it was on
that third page Google I'm talking about
the Iran sanctions this is such a
complex matter that we will make not one
not two but three videos covering all of
the various caveats in today's video
we're going to focus on one question
what does the nuclear program have to do
with the price of oil and at the end of
this video you're gonna see where I'm
coming from
[Applause]
as with every good story we should start
by introducing our characters the first
one is of course the Islamic Republic of
Iran a country known for Persian carpets
uranium enrichment and of course oil
[Music]
yep Iran has the fourth largest amount
of dinosaur juice reserves on the planet
but that is not all if you've been
subscribed to visual politic for a long
time you already know that there are
different types of crude oil for example
if you want to extract an oil barrel in
Scotland from the North Sea you've got
to build a sea platform you've got to
make a super deep hole that goes below
the bottom of the ocean and then use
rocket technology to refine it in total
a barrel has an extraction cost of more
than 44 dollars in Iran the extraction
cost is less than 1/4 of that along with
Saudi Arabia they have the cheapest oil
on the planet
[Music]
so well what's the problem chief wall
sounds great well they can't sell it to
boost countries Iran's economy is
virtually isolated from the rest of the
world this means they can only export
about three million barrels per day of
oil although due to the threat of
sanctions they're currently only
exporting about 1 million barrels per
day that might seem like a lot but it's
nothing if we compare it with the 7.5
million barrels per day currently being
exported by Saudi Arabia which is
currently producing nearly 11 million
barrels per day in total so now you
might be wondering well Simon who is
Iran's worst enemy is America right it's
Donald shock
[Music]
well you're wrong
Iran's archenemy is actually Saudi
Arabia and yeah I know both countries of
Muslim both countries follow strict
religious principles and both countries
consider human rights
well optional but not all of Islam is
the same in Iran Shia Muslims are the
majority while Saudi Arabia is a Sunni
Muslim country
so do you surmise they hate each other
but that's another story for another
video so what is Saudi Arabia's problem
well despite having oil and lots of
money their economy is the edge of
collapse
basically they spend all of their money
living like a hip-hop artist on a Friday
night and since they don't export
anything other than oil any time the
price of the barrel of oil goes down on
the market their economy goes into panic
mode so now you might be wondering well
who's Saudi Arabia's best friends well
this is actually when America comes into
the picture
[Music]
all right so the relationship between
Uncle Sam and the Saudi royal house is
not as wonderful as it seems from the
outside during the Obama administration
the White House put some pressure on the
Saudis and tried to get closer ties with
Iran this is how that nuclear deal came
about but now the president is Donald
Trump and from the moment he stepped
into the Oval Office Trump has made it
clear who his ally in the Middle East
was this is why his first official trip
was to the Saudi capital of Riyadh even
now after the alleged murder of a Saudi
journalist in Turkey Donald Trump is
trying to avoid making a firm
condemnation but the best proof of his
friendship with the Saudi royal house
are the Iran nuclear sanctions yep you
heard that right so now you might be
wondering well what does Saudi Arabia
have to do with Iran sanctions what does
oil have to do with any of this well
today we're going to answer these
questions but before we do as always
let's take a look back at the history
political bar remember the state April
2015 this was the date when Barack Obama
signed the Iran nuclear deal basically
in this agreement America China Russia
and the European Union said that they
would start trading with Iran if they
stopped their nuclear program this
explains why from one day to the next
oil exports from Iran almost doubled
just have a look at this chart
[Music]
Bryer Obama's deal Iran was making 1.8
million barrels a day after the deal
Iran increased it to as much as 3
million barrels than you cons Baha was
Spain France and other European
countries and what happens when the oil
supply on the international market
increases
well the price of a barrel of oil drops
and you just have a look at this other
chart
[Music]
at the moment the deal with signs the
brands barrel was 67 US dollars just a
year later it was twice as cheap of
course there are many other factors that
could explain this price drop but Iran
it's definitely one of them but hold on
just a minute because this really is
just the beginning of our story now
longtime visual politics subscribers
which you should be subscribed below you
already know how hard it is to extract
oil you need technology you need
companies you need money and lots of it
in other words if the National Iranian
oil company wanted to produce more oil
barrels they needed investors and this
was when the real financial bomb
absolutely drops
Saudi Arabia is considering an IPO of
Saudi Aramco potentially the world's
most valuable company
Milas pause right there why is this news
so important for our story
well let's rewind a little further
[Music]
financial explosion now I'm gonna ask
you a question what is the world's
biggest company now many of you might
reply with Apple or coca-cola or maybe
some big bank somewhere that you might
have heard of
well actually it's none of those things
the world's biggest company is actually
a raincoat
[Music]
this is Saudi Arabia's national oil
company however they waste your time
finding on the stock market not only is
a non-public Aramco is owned by the
Saudi royal family
[Music]
nonetheless having the world's biggest
company it doesn't mean you can't go
bankrupt you see as oil prices go down
Saudi Arabia is in dire straits they
need to diversify their economy they've
got to gain wealth from other things
other than just petroleum so how can
they do this well essentially the big
idea was to start a hedge fund
[Music]
Saudi Arabia wants to grow its sovereign
wealth fund to over two trillion dollars
now weird as this might seem this won't
be the first time a whole country
invested in businesses in fact the
world's biggest hedge funds actually
belongs to the Norwegian government the
Saudis they just want to make something
similar so this all sounds pretty good
so what's the problem Simon well they
need money and Swaney the world's
biggest company where'd you get money
from well you just sell some of your
company on the stock market and that
gives you all of the cash you need it's
basic business this way the Saudi royal
family would kill two birds with one
stone
first they make money and they also keep
Iran from getting that juicy investors
money remember how I told you when in
2016 Iran wanted investors to build new
oil rigs well before those investors
would consider Iran Saudi Arabia wanted
to dangle a suite a piece of candy in
front of their eyes and that was of
course a Ramco but hold on a minute it
wasn't a simple
you see listing a company on the stock
market is great because all of a sudden
you get a lot of cash
there is a problem in return for being a
publicly listed company you must make
your books publicly available after all
no one would invest in a company if they
can't see that company's financial
statements to see how they're making
money and how they're spending it in
other words you've got to be transparent
and you know remember transparency is
the least favorite word of the Saudi
royal house you see for decades the
Saudi monarchs have basically been using
Aramco for
parties luxury and all sorts of things
that you probably don't even want to
know about but this is not the problem
according to Prince Mohammed bin Salman
also known as MBS Aramco is worth two
trillion dollars there means that this
5% he wants to sell would be worth a
hundred billion dollars nonetheless as
soon as he started talking about the IPO
all these various financial analysts
started making their own estimations and
they essentially said 2 trillion dollars
bandwidth the price of oil falling like
this are you smoking crack best-case
scenario best-case you're looking at 1.2
trillion or 1.5 trillion if we're being
really really generous hella words that
financial explosion of the Aramco IPO
was supposed to be basically the game
nothing but a buzz word anytime in the
past year anyone asked Prince Salman
what he thought about this it basically
kind of respond like this yeah yeah you
know man it's a widget another day I'm
busy with print stuff later man
later hold on a moment because this is
still not the end of our story
[Music]
a crater in the markets here's another
date for you to remember May 2018 this
is the moment when Trump broke the Iran
deal and announced a new economic
sanction but not only that he also
promised secondary sanctions against
those countries that would not comply in
other words if any country wants to buy
oil from Iran well they'd also have to
deal with Uncle Sam and do not forget
here that that also includes the ins
higher European Union other countries
don't really care China for example has
said you know I don't care Trump
whatever we're gonna buy all from Iran
India of the second-largest clientís
said that they will try to reduce their
imports but they can't a hundred percent
stop buying all from the country of the
ayatollahs
[Music]
nonetheless it seems like the EU will
have to follow Donald Trump's of a
letter even if they don't want to but
this is a matter actually going to
discuss in the next video the truth is
nowadays Europe is buying more than 1
million barrels from Iran every day this
means if we take a run out of the
equation we have a whole 1 million
barrel order of that somebody has to
fill because you know one thing is
absolutely clear throughout all of this
everybody needs that sweet sweet
dinosaur juice and I bet you can guess
now who is very very happy to be filling
that void
Trump pressure Saudi Arabia to increase
oil production nevertheless Saudi Arabia
just increased its production by 600,000
barrels Russia has done so by 200,000
and if you do the math it's not tricky
you get 800,000 barrels we still need
more to fill that huge void and you
probably also remember what happens when
we reduce the oil offering on the
international market oh yeah supply and
demand kicks in and the price of that
oil barrel goes up let's go back to our
brent chart if you pay attention you
will see that right after Trump started
talking about the Iran sanctions the
Dino juice that went up to $80 in other
words things are starting to go really
really well for the Saudi economy Saudi
Arabia's sovereign wealth fund raises
eleven billion dollar loan so what does
this mean well two things on the one
hand the Saudi royal family now has a
lot more breathing space for that Aramco
IPO the company is now profitable enough
that they can wait before getting to the
stock market so old lazy prince he
doesn't need to worry about it on the
other hand if they could keep the oil
barrel at 80 US dollars it would be way
easier to hit that initial valuation of
two trillion dollars and while that
explains news like this
[Music]
sorry Crown Prince says IPO for oil
giant Saudi Aramco will happen by early
2021 meanwhile there are two things we
should cover first the Islamic Republic
of Iran is at the edge of economic
collapse this is leading to protests
social unrest and an authoritarian
regime that is having a very bad
situation seconds we have the big
question is the EU gonna comply with
Trump's sanctions the debate it really
couldn't be hotter these days you act to
protect firms from Donald Trump's
sanctions against Iran so now the
question is do you think we are at the
beginning of the end of the ayatollah
regime do you think the european union
will keep from buying oil from Iran well
we'd love to read your thoughts and
theories and in the following videos
we're gonna see quite how much they
match with our own also do visit the
reconsider media web site the podcast
that provided the vocals in this episode
that are not mine in the meantime don't
forget that we publish brand new videos
every week so do hit that subscribe
button and the little bell icon so
you'll see a notification any time we
post an update and if you like this
video please do give us a thumbs up and
as always I'll see you next time and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear more of my lovely voice don't
forget to check out the reconsidered
podcast at reconsider mediacom
reconsider is a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your views by
providing context but we don't do the
thinking for you
you